this place is a mess can you believe I'm
letting you in here right now
the worst part is almost none of these
come from actual humans see 20% off at a
store I bought a shirt at once delete
yes that's beautiful really beautiful
delete sure I could individually delete
and unsubscribe from each and every one
of these 5,000 emails and I could also
ask for carpal tunnel for my birthday
instead existing email tools and other
apps like unroll me and Maelstrom take
care of all that hard work for me while
I just sit back and relax but work
everybody
keep it up sure there's some setup but
it's fairly easy here are the three
things I did to get those thousands of
unwanted robotic generated messages down
to almost zero first I did a massive
purge of all these messages and instead
of going message by message I use
Maelstrom after analyzing my large Gmail
inbox in about an hour it organized my
messages by sender and gave me a message
count you can then delete all of them in
one fell swoop and select others at the
same time I'll really miss you all 178
Banana Republic emails just be careful
the interface can be a little confusing
and lists emails from important people
right next to the others after deleting
close to 3000 messages it was time to
plug the hole and unsubscribe and no I
didn't come down here every time and
click that hittin unsubscribe button
instead you can now unsubscribe right
from Gmail and outlook.com
by clicking right on a button Maelstrom
also has a similar feature that lets you
delete and unsubscribe at the same time
I unsubscribe from tons of marketing
emails and newsletters and it felt great
goodbye 1-800 flowers but if you're the
type of person that likes to look at
those from time to time a service called
unrolled dot me can come in handy
instead of individual emails from a
bunch of companies enroll dot me will
roll them all into one daily bulk email
new
it can include social media alerts to
the service also lets you easily
unsubscribe from newsletters you get
sick of the third thing I did was set up
filters for unimportant messages in case
they did make their way through if you
have the Priority Inbox enabled on Gmail
you can have your important messages go
to the main inbox and the others go
right to the social media or promotions
inbox outlook comm has a similar feature
where it automatically sword's your
social media and newsletters with Yahoo
your best bet is to create filters based
on emails but I also like a third party
service called sandbox which
automatically puts junk messages into a
folder it's looking pretty good in here
I cut down on all the junk and I'm
subscribed with a few clicks in
Maelstrom and now I only hear from the
good ones in my daily unrolled me email
best of all now only the real humans end
up in my main inbox so does anyone know
how to unsubscribe from them